our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us one of
the biggest divisions in Congress is the
hardest to see who can afford to work
there as an intern Congress is not
required to pay those interns and most
members do not but we found one
innovative nonprofit that connects
low-income students with congressional
internships that some thought they could
not afford Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill Nancy good morning good morning
yeah think about this most members of
Congress are worth more than a million
dollars and yet most of them don't pay
their interns a dime and that puts this
key stepping stone out of reach for a
lot of talented young people who just
can't work for free in one of the
nation's most expensive cities each year
8,000 interns come to Congress but for
some Capitol Hill can be a tough climb
I come from a town of 380 people single
mom grew up in a trailer Texas native
Audrey Henson had to take on a $6,500
loan and two jobs just to afford her
unpaid internship here seven years ago
not only are you being asked to front
the bill for housing which can be
between fifteen hundred and two grand a
month then you have to pay for your food
every day this is pretty essential that
experience led her to create college to
Congress a nonprofit that gives
low-income students the money and
training to succeed here do you have any
idea who I am
you said your name was Melissa more than
1,000 students applied this year for 18
grants first I was like this project
gonna be true Ryan she sure went back to
college in Ohio after a career in the
Navy and has a seven-year-old son
Marissa Reyes from Washington State is
the daughter of Mexican immigrants one
of my earliest memories was working in
agricultural fields with my parents over
the summer is college to Congress spends
26 thousand dollars on each intern to
cover flights housing and food $26,000
for the
that's a game-changer that's a good
income from where I come from the money
also helps them build a professional
wardrobe think about how much a suit is
and you can't just buy one you're
working five days a week another
obstacle wealthier interns don't face I
had a mental breakdown in like at JC
Penney's in the sock aisle because there
was like 15 types of socks and I didn't
know which one to get did you own a tie
I did I did own a tie but to the program
is now in its third year with backing
from big names like Toyota Facebook and
Google South Carolina Republican Tim
Scott was an early champion growing up
in a single-parent household mired in
poverty but one thing you did a lot of
them's work so working for free is just
something that never would have been an
option for you
no I think it isn't for the average kid
in this country Senator Scott pays his
interns but most in Congress don't what
we've learned is that by having a
cross-section of all of America employed
here I serve hopefully all of America
better Ryan she sir says interning for a
Senate subcommittee is already opening
doors he never knew existed this is
insane
I'm just meeting people and they're like
you want a job networking is huge so you
can already see how this experience
might change your whole job trajectory
absolutely yes Marissa Reyes is making
contacts to interning for Democratic
leader Chuck Schumer it's funny because
everyone's like when you get coffee when
I get coffee and I'm like oh you guys do
you like coffee 87% of college to
Congress alumni have stayed in public
service there is a generation that is
hungry to be a part of the difference
who isn't desensitized like a lot of
other Americans are but who really do
see an opportunity to fix this what's
your ultimate goal
I just want Congress to look like
America I want the American people to be
heard I asked senator Scott Scott why
more lawmakers don't pay their interns
and he said he thinks it's just not on
their radar he added that he thinks it's
a great investment
because a lot of these interns are
smarter than the members they work for
his words not love this story great
program Nancy thank you Jesus
cheers to Audrey and I love what you
said I want Congress to look more like
America I also think we can we can help
that kid who had the mental breakdown in
the sakai